hi I'm Ricky Gervais and today I'll be
doing the wired auto-complete interview
from home let's see what the Internet
want to know so these are frequently
asked questions about me I've been away
one wants to know these things but
that's gone I'll answer some if I know
the answer where wicked ways
where does ricky gervais come from I
mean do they meet biologically or was
that my dad gave a half of his genetic
material my mum gave half of hers I come
from reading which is I don't know what
you call it it's a big town 40 miles
outside London where is ricky gervais
house
Hampstead right obviously the most if I
just said the address that's close
enough it's announced dude yeah why
Ricky Gervais why doesn't Mickie James
Drive laziness I guess I've never
bothered I've lived in London since I
was you know 19 so you know the two more
buses it was easier or take a cab I wish
I could but I can't be bothered to learn
I think that I've everything I wish I
could speak French but I can't be
bothered to learn so laziness but you
can't drink and drive so what's the
point
why did Ricky Gervais Roast Hollywood I
think it's what I was paid to do you
know I'm a court jester
I made the decision I've done it five
times over the last ten years and every
time it's like do you pan at the 200
people in the room or the 200 million
people watching at home with no
competition that the people at home
aren't winning awards they're not
millionaires what's in it for them to
watch the richest most privileged people
in the world just win an award no I
tried to make it a spectator sport um so
that's
that's why they can take it how we need
a vase how can I meet me back it's you
can't
I've got armed guards and electrified
fences and lasers I've got a moat around
this castle with alligators how which is
Ricky Gervais is well but a moat with
alligators that's how a mobile
alligators none of your business
how does Ricky Gervais is pronounce his
name Ricky Gervais is if you did it saw
like that phonetically it'd be like jerk
it'd be a J apostrophe be a Z e Gervaise
I don't know both correct pronunciation
it's French obviously oh sure they hello
oh I learned everything from Jarvis
journalist Gerdes the most common one is
the that make they make the S sound is
for the Bizet sound so I go to base I
think that's the most common particular
merica jar base but I say Gervaise is
Ricky Gervais is is Ricky Gervais a US
citizen no I'm not I'm a British citizen
nothing more to add to that really is
Ricky Gervais is wealthy well um yeah
don't worry about me I'm doing all right
yeah is Ricky Gervais is related to
David Bowie well yeah I suppose so
distantly we're all related aren't we
but no not in the 90 immediate sense not
that we were I haven't worked out but
we're all related are we really
I mean we're great apes I think I looked
like him when I was younger a little bit
or trying to anyway I've got his teeth
as well I suppose we talked similar to
an American is really is married to Jane
Fallon not legally not in the eyes of
God we are really but not we haven't
done the paperwork or had a wedding no
is Ricky Gervais is cancelled every day
I reckon every day by someone but
luckily it means nothing
what Ricky Gervais is what inspired
Ricky Gervais is after life I was on
tour with you mommy and I was only doing
like 90 minutes work a day and I felt a
bit guilty and I thought I should
probably do another TV series unlike all
the other ones I've done where the
character came first
like David Brent existed before the
office daring existed before
Darren etc this one the idea came to me
rather like a movie idea like a high
concept movie I did and I thought
imagine a man who didn't care about
living anymore and one day he's gonna
commit suicide he could do what he
wanted because he didn't care what he
could just have one last Hirai could do
and say what he wanted and he's always
got suicide to fall back on so it was
mucker like a superpower like nothing
could hurt him he was invincible and
then the next thing I thought oh what
what would why would he nearly think so
oh he lost everything and what would be
won't be losing everything I thought
well for me to be that you're your
soulmate your life partner and I suppose
that's when he got a little bit more
serious but the big concept was imagine
you could say and do everything cuz you
didn't care whether you lived or died
that was the only thing what made look
at you as famous I guess being in the
office but I don't know really I think
that you're famous to different people
for different things like kids
recognized me from the nightly Museum
and the Muppets and then some people
recognized me just because I don't even
think they know I'm a comedian they
noticed me because I do lots of animal
activism when they're into that so I
don't know but I'd say what follows me
round would be the creator of the office
or David Brent yeah what did we do I say
to Mel Gibson well I think I know what
they mean when he to the podium without
the last time I introduced him I said
what does Shiva teaming mean I think
that's what they're referring to
they must have leaked out the word
what was Ricky Gervais drinking I think
that means at the Golden Globes as well
listening it was a beer
standard beer I think was Foster's
because I think that's like you know
three point six or something so you can
drink those all night and not be drunk
that's our professional I am I will only
drink beer all night when I'm working
what did you guys do back that's
bursting general of the internet like
it's my going to train people what did
he do now
what did he say who did the annoy faster
it depends it depends what they you're
watching this what did I do
haha sorry deep Ricky jemaine's did you
guys cancel his tour no no it's all
postponed
I've never cancel the gig I've never
cancelled we gave up in ill I've been up
there in that they're dying one gig I've
thought flu and I was there and I was
coughing the worst thing yeah I mean I
had temperature sick nor was the other
side to be a toilet but the worst thing
is a cough cuz he could come a punchline
I was drinking sort of like cough
medicine and I was having you know cold
remedies turned a beer a little beer
that never anyone but no I haven't
canceled the tour I've postponed
what did Antonia Banderas say to Ricky
Gervais I have no idea I didn't I
introduced him like as a joke once I
didn't know what he was I didn't know
what he was staying so I don't know what
he said to me I didn't I couldn't
understand him what did you do I study
when everything like s at school I went
to university to study biology about
University and I thought why am i done
this this is real work this is a proper
science and stuff I've got I've got 40
hours a week nine o'clock lectures this
is not I came to university to join a
band after a few weeks of that I did
philosophy which was seven hours a week
and I got my degree in philosophy
when triple A's when this wiki device
humanity or Netflix it's not now
so he's these questions are three years
old let's just kidnap most someone did
three years ago and they're watching
this and they're going oh great thanks
thanks for having me it's on now
Wendy pretty amazed get ollie autumn of
2016 on the Jonathan Ross show which is
like our Jimmy Fallon however he knew
that we've recently lost our cat Colin
he checked with my girlfriend Joan that
we'd want a new cat so it wasn't just a
gifted cat and they kept a secret from
me and then on air he said he'd got cut
for me and he gave me lovely Lily and
she died a few weeks ago she would have
been seventeen on July the 9th when did
Ricky Gervais start comedy I've always
been doing it I've always been annoying
people from the age of about six or
seven just I just wasn't getting paid
for it until I was about eight who knows
who did Ricky Gervais say is coming for
you again that's the globe's when I said
this isn't just about the people in
front of the camera people behind the
scenes here producers execs from all
different backgrounds but they all got
one thing in common they're terrified of
Ronan Farrow he's coming for you who
need Ricky Gervais he's make fun of
everyone from everyone who does Ricky
Gervais is support football England I
know where the other team I have another
team probably in my twin isn't it was my
last time I ever said I supported a team
but England the only time I watch soccer
as you make a say now as you stolen the
term football for a ball that you don't
kick you hold it in your hand this
should be called handball football we
had football we kick the ball was called
football
why did we have to change our name
soccer
we had football
so yeah England does Ricky Gervais is
does ricky gervais spake time I do yeah
well ma'am
I've played since on about fourteen I
sort of taught myself I'm okay
I did it took me a summer I didn't do it
to be a guitarist I did it to write
songs so as soon as I knew three chords
I was writing songs but then so Bob
Dylan at least he's amazing does Ricky
Gervais he's like Steve Carell yeah I do
he's brilliant lovely man as well lovely
family man just good at his job
I know it easy properly be knows and he
said being lovely email about afterlife
one and two yeah I do like to grow
lovely talented hard-working brilliant
funny clever actor so yes
can Ricky Gervais can really give a
stack balance can make a face tap dance
oh I know why Muppets movie where are we
doing a dance that's the magic of movies
can move is very sweet French I can
order a beer in most European languages
I have to say no no I can't speak French
thank you very much for your questions
from the internet over the last 10 years
okay we're waiting patiently for the
answer
- Ricky Gervais